[Music]
let's go out to Vermont and talk to Jen
what's up
Jen well hello what's
up um I'm don't know what to lead with
how about this start singing your
favorite song and I'll rank you one to
10 on how good you are let's
not awesome so hey no it's all good I'm
glad that you're here what's up yeah um
okay um typed up some notes yesterday
and they're nowhere near with me so that
they that's not even hey can you do me a
huge favor I'm uh your your thing's
cutting in and out oh that's terrible
I'm sorry is that better keep talking
okay so anyway I don't know if I should
lead with thinking back on it I'm third
generation of not good marriage and I
want to stop that so my daughter's got a
good chance or should I lead with that
my husband's grumpiness is kind of
becoming his status quo and when he
becomes happy I don't even know what to
do with that or should I lead
with we've been married 12 years
and if we've been physically intimate
five times I'd be
surprised yeah let's go with option
C
okay um that will get most YouTube clips
um actually the uh clicks the
um I'm really interested in your second
question um let's let's loot back there
because I already have a sense but I'm
just guessing um I'm just I'll just be
fishing in the dark but that's a
fascinating question you just asked um
Mr y'all been married 12 years You' have
had sex five times you think no probably
yes I mean I'm not really exaggerating
one way or the other with that
why listen counseling 101 never ask why
questions um so thankfully we're not
doing therapy like why like what what's
happened over a decade that either of
y'all put up with
that
um oh my goodness I don't even it um
it depends on who you talk to I'm only
talking to Jen I understand that's true
okay so for me it was
um it turned
into lack
of lack of trust in the fact that lack
of support lack of I don't feel like
this is a partnership in any way shape
or form um I was definitely feeling like
a single mom I was hold on hold on hold
on hold on hold on hold on
does he want to sleep with you and you
just
won't or has he had no interest in you
for 12
years well right now there's really no
interest yeah it's he's 12 years he's so
mad okay but um but there there was he
had a like when you'all got me most
people have I'm say most when we first
first got married no the I was like are
we G to like I believe the technical
term is consummate uhhuh and like 6
months into the marriage we went back to
a marriage counselor that we had seen
when we were engaged and my question was
we haven't had sex
yet so I was the one pushing them Jen I
am rarely speechless and you just got me
you got me it's a little nutty wow I
mean I would say nutty but it it's very
very very abnormal
but so my question to you is 6 months is
a really long
time for some six hours six minutes is a
really long time like what were the
conversations
like
um it really
weren't and it's it's the weirdest
yeah and it's shocking to me because
we're
both I don't want to to we're both smart
people has nothing to do intelligence
yeah has nothing to do that we have
we're morons when it comes to any of
this okay let's and and I'll be straight
up
um 15 minutes
ago my husband was just sitting at my
desk just anyway trying to get get a
sell anyway and he was at my desk and he
saw my day planner open and he was on
hold and he goes hey what's that and I
was on hold for you uhuh and in it I had
written you know this appointment in my
day planner had to he's like what's that
and he goes you're not doing that are
you and I'm like well yeah I'm going to
and he's like
what and I was my whole thing was I'm
like because
I'll grasp at
straws I lost what you just said what'
you say ma'am I said I'll just grasp it
anything not to like be little what you
do no no trust me it's it's def you were
at you were scraping the bottom of the
barrel here here's um here's what's it
feels like okay yes
sir
um it feels like one of a couple of
things there is way way way more to the
story and when I say say that I mean
like abuse like some severe trauma
responses some very significant not
emotional distress but mental health
disorders there's something else going
on here that's number one number
two
um and by the way you and I just are
meeting I'm very very direct okay
because in most of that is because I've
I I love you and most of that is because
I've got a very compressed time right so
it's only
um it sounds like for 10 or 12 years
you've been stepping over $1,000 checks
and $10000 bills to pick up
pennies like we're grasping grasping at
straws here but we haven't sat down and
asked our husband
like I want to have sex with you can we
can we try
this I feel distant from you can we plug
in I feel like a single mom can we
connect
here and instead of entering into that
conversation that admittedly may go
awful may end up in US
separating instead of us but it may also
end up in US fixing
everything instead of that we wait six
months and then we just call a
professional it's like a tiny little
fire getting lit in in the in the actual
fireplace but we just don't deal with it
we just don't deal with it and 6 months
later the whole House's on fire now we
got to call the fire
department right and
so I guess Circle back how I mean I
can't unwind this in a in a in a one
small segment how can I help you right
now what are you aiming for what's your
goal
here my goal would be I really like when
you mentioned to parents where they're
like e my relationship with my kid I
don't know and whatever age if they're
still at home they're like get a
notebook have the kid write something
you write something have the kid and I'm
like what a
basic it's basic that works that
builds I guess I'm
just you you I only tell parents to do
that with kids because kids don't have
the intellectual plus the emotional
ability to articulate in a
conversation right adults should have
that and so if you're unable to if you
and your husband are unable to sit
across the table and say
dude we have been living a farce for 12
years cuz you calling and saying I'm
frustrated my husband's
grumpy you me that's like that's what we
call it right yeah but I mean that's
like your house burning down to the
ground and you calling 911 cuz it's hot
outside that's not the issue
here you saying hey I am committed to
being the one who breaks the cycle of
bad
marriages and out of the
gate six months and I say intimacy I'm
not talking about
intercourse intimacy being able to just
talk about it with each
other and so instantly the recipe for a
marriage that's dysfunctional or that's
not working for either of you that
creates a home that's full of tension
and Chaos repeats itself
again and that's not on you that's on
that's on the whole
system you see what I'm saying
yeah
completely I've been working with a
killer therapist okay for
nine months now okay awesome for me if
it was just me oneon-one
um from my perspective I'm radically
Different awesome the people that are
really close to me um some co-workers
they can totally tell a difference they
said so I'm like okay that's
cool
um my husband obviously not really it
that's not surprising to me because just
one change yeah well as Esther Perell
tells us she y'all are in the dance yall
have an address the dance right like
y'all have a rhythm in a routine in fact
you don't even know what to do with him
when he's not grumpy and so the
incentive inside his own home is to be
grumpy it's like you don't even know
what to say to him when he starts
speaking to you in Italian you just want
him to speak Spanish because that's the
language you know know that's the
language your kid knows that's the
language the house Dynamic
knows and so even when he Peaks his head
out and and there's
joy it's not met with any sort of
reciprocal Joy it's met with who who is
this and he's like oh completely and it
goes back to Grump right so there's this
Dynamic set up in your
home right and the only way that gets
busted is somebody you've heard me say
this you someone's got to turn the
lights on turn the music off stop
dancing
and what does that mean in real life
that's that's a big metaphor people ask
me like what does that actually mean
that means you getting a babysitter for
your child your kids and you sitting
across the table from your husband and
saying we haven't had sex in 10
years you don't like being around me and
I don't even know how to interact with
you when you're
grumpy I want a different kind of
marriage are you in to build something
completely
new based on Grace and forgiveness and
trying new things moving forward because
what we've been doing does not
work anything short of that you're going
to go to therapy you're going to become
this amazing new person on the inside
you're going to walk back into your
house right back into the same costume
that you always wear until one of you
either has the courage to call
it or one of the other one does
something just so dumb cheats on
somebody steals something from somebody
does something awful that then everybody
can go look what they did um or your
child starts acting out to try to get
somebody's attention to say please can
we cut the tension on this home because
I can't
breathe often the way the way I phrase
this is you have to choose your heart
there's not an easy path out of
this
right it's either going to end in a in a
in a
supernova or it's going to end in a
whimper and an
ash or it's going to be something built
completely new it's going to be amazing
why are you so avoiding of that
conversation is he abusing
you no there's a lot of
um everything is said you're trying to
accuse me of stuff here you come you're
blaming me again for everything
you're it all is and I'm like I'm not
blaming you I want to just can we just
have a normal conversation can we like
actually write things on paper can we
together
to I brought some of the suggestions
that my therapist has said some of the
things that I've heard on your show and
um and
it's it turns into these Al another
argument another full shutdown I'll have
another like five six days of no
communication so behavior is a language
what's he telling
you
that I'll I'll give you his language he
does not want to be married to
you that's what his Lang that's what his
behavior is telling
you
tell me I'm wrong I love being
wrong I'd like
to but that's been the language since we
were
dating
okay until you choose to live in that
reality you're going to continue Chasing
Ghosts
it's going to be
exhausting here's the other thing you
may be
wrong there's been a couple of times in
my marriage over 21 years 20 and a half
years when I when he's been in his happy
mood or we can actually have a
conversation he looks at me and he's
even like you know for him shed tears a
few times while seeing it and he says
that he said I am married to
you because for any reason whether it
was a good reason or a bad reason I
believe God brought us together and I
believe that I on purpose chose you to
be my
wife he has said that probably three
times three or four times in the last
year and a
half and I'm like so do I believe that
it it doesn't matter what he
says what if I just walked down the
street Jen announcing to the world how
in shape I am right doesn't
matter God wants me to be in shape and I
chose this
gim and I just announced that God called
me to be ripped and I chose this gy
do you ever go in that gym and work out
no I'm not talking to you for six days
for even asking that question you
bastard like what like what do you I
don't care what he says so what's the
conversation that I have then I'll tell
you the I I tell you the one I had in my
house I've had it twice maybe three
times maybe four times over 21 years it
is two adults sitting across the table
and I think I or I don't remember how I
preface it I don't like to think of the
specifics but
um we need to have a very direct
grown-up hard conversation that's going
to be very emotional and I just want us
both to prep for
it and it goes something like this
marriage as it currently is cannot
continue I do not feel in my body that
you want to be married to me
anymore um if you do I've got some real
challenges because I'm not I'm not
feeling it I'm not accepting it and I'm
not being a good partner to you we got
to do something completely new are you
in and every time the other person has
said absolutely all
in but somebody has to sit at a grown-up
table and even if you have to call out
every time we have a hard conversation
you don't talk to me for six days you
shut down you say oh what about me we're
not doing any of that
today this is two grown-ups having a
grown-up
conversation are we going to stay
married and here's what you have to have
already
prepared I need moving forward not you
haven't done this and you haven't done
that that's not it cannot work that way
because if you come at him that way he
has to defend himself and his defense
strategy is to shut down and become a
joy vacuum in his own house right
right and so the only way forward is for
you to say I need
physical and sexual intimacy in my
home I need to be able to have
conversations good bad scary vulnerable
hilarious
silly I got to be able to share my life
with my
partner and on whatever the things you
need I don't and I don't know what that
is I don't know what that is for you but
you're going to have to be able to say
those things out loud and this is
hard but I think you be very clear if
you get up and walk away from from the
table I will understand that you want
this marriage to be
over if you don't talk to me for five
days after this discussion I understand
you are not interested in in changing
the way this relationship
works if you're going to sit at this
table and we're going to we're going to
figure this thing out then I recognize
that you're all
in going backwards over the last 12
years my gut tells me if I was talking
to him there would be enough blame to go
around Maybe not maybe I'm maybe you're
protecting him and whatever maybe he's
got some major psychological challenges
that you have just had to dance around
for 12 years
maybe but going back and blaming is not
going to help anybody there's going to
be an important forensic accounting of
the last 12 years hey this is how you've
dealt with conflict I can't have that
moving forward you got to be present
with me give me some tools so I can
whenever I need to bring something up to
you it won't doesn't shut you down
because just shutting down doesn't solve
our
problem we're going to have to put sex
on a calendar we're going to have to put
weekly meetings on a calendar we're
going to have to have a budget together
we're going to have to have parenting
conversations we're going to have to be
married I'm sorry Jen I wish I had more
for
you I wish I could just pass this one
and be like ah here it is this one's
tough this one's tough this one's
tough
somebody's got to flip the lights on
someone's got to turn the music off and
stop the dance and just say hey this is
the state of our marriage we're choosing
reality it's the state of our
marriage I'm going forward no more we
got to be different starting now are you
in let me know how it goes Jen we'll be
thinking about
you